A new study out of Harvard says a newly discovered
text that Jesus may have had a wife could
hold water... that was then subsequently turned
into wine.
Welcome to DNews, I'm Ross Everett and we're
going to have some fun with religious texts.
A sentence that's normally a lie, but walk
with me.
Across water.
See?
The fun's already starting.
You've heard of Jesus, right?
Carpenter, insightful guy, son of God.
Well, recently, a new text was found where
the unmarried messiah was said to have referenced
his wife.
Specifically the ancient text reads "Jesus
said to them, my wife"
Seeing as how this was thousands of years
ago, this probably wasn't a Borat reference,
unless Jesus was super into inane prophecies
and wanted to appeal to the brothers of Theta
Beta Kappa.
But more likely it alludes to the idea that
Jesus had a wife, and like other men, would
talk to his friends about her.
This could be troublesome as it's written
that Christ never knew the touch of a woman,
but if you ask any married man that could
still hold true.
Whether or not Jesus had a wife was a hot
button issue especially amongst early Christians
who debated celibacy versus if it was okay
to have a family.
Now here's where Harvard comes in, because
only something this big, this special, this
groundbreaking, it has a shot of getting into
Harvard.
Even without extra curriculars.
So, Harvard takes a look at this text because
you gotta make sure it's real.
We can't just take a piece of paper's word
for it.
You've got to wine and dine it a little bit.
Romance it before you start dating.
Carbon dating, that is.
Let's take a quick look at the found text
itself: the text was revealed to the public
back in 2012.
It's written in Coptic and is around the size
of a business card.
And Harvard's test say the papyrus most likely
dates to eighth century Egypt based on the
radiocarbon dating and the ink's chemical
composition.
They go on to say "If it was written in the
eighth or even the ninth century, it's still
an ancient document" and if real would fall
into the category of gospel.
But, let's not go drawing a wedding ring on
every picture of Christ just yet as a challenger
has entered the tournament by the name of
Brown University who points out that the text
conta ins grammatical errors a native Coptic
speaker would not make.
Mind you, Harvard refuted that by saying that
the grammatical errors match an informal style
that's found in other ancient Coptic texts.
Kind of like a doge version of gospel.
Trademark.
I'm a genius.
What do you guys think?
What's the craziest thing you've ever found
out about someone you thought you knew?
Let us know in the comments down below.
And don't forget to check out all of this
stuff over here to learn yourself something
more.
I'm Ross Everett, and you all are just lovely.